[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les soirs d'Halloween sont
toujours témoins d'événements étranges
saviez-vous que les bonbons d'Halloween
contiennent des colorants E12 qui sont
des allergènes et donc susceptibles de
provoquer des
cancers maintenant que vous êtes
terrifié laissez-moi vous raconter un
autre événement étrange c'est l'histoire
de trois hommes trois youtubeurs qui
s'étaient donné rendez-vous dans un
chalet loin de tout pour écrire
l'épisode spécial Halloween de leur
série ce qu'il ne savait pas c'était que
ce chalet avait été construit sur les
ruines d'un ancien restaurant indien
[Musique]
voilà ça ressemble exactement à ton
salon on va pouvoir commencer à bosser
maintenant allez du coup on va commencer
à écrire sur le
PC les jeux ouais ouais tiens
merci en fait pourquoi on est venu à
l'autre bout du monde pour écrire bah
pour trouver
l'inspiration du coup alors vendredi 13
je pourrais commencer par exemple en
disant que c'est adapté du film vendi
qui est sorti en 80 que c'est un des
piliers du cinéma d'horreur et des
slashheerss alors c'est quoi un
slashheer le slashheer est un genre
cinématographique américain sous genre
du film d'horreur qui a connu son âge
d'or dans les années 80 et qui met en
scène une série de meurtres perpétré par
un tueur masqué qui assassine les uns
après les autres de jeunes adultes ok B
c'est cool ben merci Karim c'est sympa
d'être venu jusqu'ici pour participer
mais de rien tout le plaisir est pour
moi et merci à vous d'avoir refait tout
ce décor c'est un énorme gâi de moyens
le problème c'est qu'en jeu vidéo un
seul méchant et plein de gentil ben ça
marche pas puisque le jeu vidéo c'est
même le contraire par essence un seul
gentil contre plein de méchant e ce
graphique est raciste la logique
voudrait donc qu'on incarne le méchant
mais non ben du coup c'est parti pour
vendredi 13 alors je rappelle le
scénario des moniteurs d'une colonie de
vacances doivent préparer le camp de
Crystal Lake pour l'arrivée des gamins
sauf que manque de bol ils se mettent à
mourir un par un et donc dans ce jeu on
incarne les moniteurs du camp de
vacances qui face à la présence d'un
tueur en série sur le camp décide de
faire la seule chose logique à faire
allumer toutes les cheminées du camp
non sans déconner c'est ce que le jeu te
dit de faire oh non la lumière 12 est
abisée d'un feu de cheminée ma seule
faiblesse donc le jeu c'est une espèce
de Side scroller tout à fait
classiquevec un bouton pour sauter un
bouton pour taper et il faut avancer
pour
aller
ok je viens de commencer la partie là oh
non mais c'est quoi votre problème là
sérieusement [ __ ] mais j'ai compté
entre le moment où le jeu démarre et le
moment oùon me saute DESS il y a 6
secondes ouais ben alors tu vas très
vite te mettre en Do d'Al fion et boire
une tisan pour te calmer ok JEE merde
donc le début du jeu tu choisis ton
moniteur alors moi j'ai pris George qui
a l'air ravi de se battre contre un
tueur en série et donc le jeu nous dit
d'aller de maison en maison pour aller
allumer les feux de cheminée et secourir
les enfants parce que contrairement au
film Les enfants sont déjà là alors
autant on peut dire qui bon ils se sont
fait surprendre parce qu'il y avait un
tueur dans le camp c'était pas prévu au
programme autant c'est quand même le
pire endroit du monde pour installer un
[ __ ] de camp de vacances il y a des
zombies qui sortent du sol des créatures
dans le Maré des corbau géants qui
t'attaquent des loups dans la forêt et
ben dis donc j'aimerais bien voir la
brochure du camp c'est génial on peut
même nourrir les animaux et en plus non
seulement tu te bats avec l'arme la plus
nulle du monde he des petits cailloux
mais aussi tu es visiblement trop con
pour bien les lancer oh oui je sens que
je vais adorer ce
jeu donc le vrai but du jeu qui n'a rien
à voir avec les cheminées je sais pas
pourquoi le jeu te dis ça c'est de tuer
Jason avant de perdre tous les moniteurs
ou de perdre les 15 enfants et si tu
arrives à en sauver ne serait-ce qu'un
seul et bien c'est gagn bravo et bravo
tout le monde c'est une victoire non
mais vous êtes malade on a perdu 5
moniteurs et 14 enfants ont été tués
peut-être mais il reste Bobby allez
Bobby tape mon sec et pour trouver Jason
il faut aller donc sur ces maisons qui
clignotent et qui sont signalés par ce
son de merde super agaçant que tu vas
entendre tout le temps dans ce jeu c'est
le son qui signale que Jason est en
train d'attaquer quelqu'un alors ça peut
être un enfant ou un autre moniteur
alors finalement vous me direz c'est
quoi le problème de ce jeu c'est que ce
jeu est dur mais il est pas juste dur
maintenant ce jeu était déjà super dur à
l'époque et le système de jeu fait que
tu perds des vie même quand tu joues
parfaitement bien Jason peut se déplacer
de maison en maison et tuer les autres
moniteurs qui sont dispersés dans les
maisons aux quatre coins du jeu et ces
moniteurs sont tes vies en quelque sorte
puisque quand tu meurs tu changes de
moniteur que tu contrôles donc Jason va
littéralement aller tuer tes vies
pendant que tu les joues pas non mais
qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça je veux
dire pour prendre un exemple c'est comme
si dans je sais pas moi Sonic tu avais
un ennemi qui allait te poutrer tes vies
dans le menu pendant que tu joues je je
dire est-ce queun jeu peut te la mettre
plus profondément que ça parce qu'après
faut pas compter sur les moniteurs pour
réagir hein quand Jason entre dans une
maison avec un moniteur tu as le bip qui
commence qui t'avertit que le moniteur
est attaqué et les moniteurs ils font
quoi et ben ils reste là voilà la vie
est belle c'est cool oui Jason euh il
est juste à côté moi je vais rester là
hein je vais te regarder en train de te
battre contre le méchant allez bonne
chance et c'est pareil aussi quand tu
rentres dans la maison a Jason tu es
obligé de tourner dans tous les sens
dans toute la maison pour le trouver je
veux dire ça va c'est bon je sais qu'il
est là il y a son nom marqué en gros en
bas et puis bon c'est pas comme s'il
pouvait vraiment se cacher ici c'est une
[ __ ] de cabane en bois vide sans aucun
meuble et d'ailleurs c'est quoi ces
maisons de merde ils allaient vraiment
recevoir des gamell là dedans pour les
vacances allez bon séjour et fais gaffe
au
loup bon bref j'arrête pas d'en parler
mais le but du jeu c'est de tuer Jason
alors bon tu vas le croiser en extérieur
des fois là ça va il est tuable mais
surtout tu vas leis dans les maisons
avec son survette Adidas de merde là le
but c'est de lui baisser suffisamment la
vie pour le faire partir en esquivant
ses coups mais l'esquive de ses coups
mais ça demande même pas du réflexe on n
plus dans le réflexe à ce stade là on
est dans l'instinct je veux dire mais
c'est incroyable il y aurait juste deux
petites Fram deux petites frames de plus
où tu le vois juste amorcer son coup je
dis pas mais là c'est là c'est gen juste
il arrive sur toi tu es
mort ah ok bon ben toi et tes amis être
mort voilà au moins ça laisse pas de
place au doute hein hein c'est pas genre
tu as perdu ou genre Game Over ou je
sais pas essaye encore non c'est non tu
es mort va te faire [ __ ] voilà en fait
c'est pas tant que Jon est super dur à
battre et tu peux esquiver ses coups en
appuyant sur diagonale bas gauche ou bas
droite mais c'est juste que quand tu
esquives ces coups tu reviens juste
après dans sa position initiale or ben
des fois il met deux coups de suite
d'affilé au même endroit et du coup tu
es obligé de te prendre au moins un des
deux [ __ ] ça fait chier et l'autre con
là que je suis venu sauver [ __ ] il
peut pas m'aider et ben franchement ça
va tu gères j'ai voulu t'aider un moment
mais après je me suis dit ça va tu l'as
tu l'as et des fois par miracle quand tu
réussis à le battre il t'attaque direct
à la sortie de la maison mais [ __ ] là
c'est la goutte d'eau qui me casse les
couilles maintenant il me restait deux
points de vie qu'est-ce que tu veux que
je foute espèce de crétin ah oui et en
plus je l'ai pas dit mais tu peux aussi
carrément le croiser dans le
lac génial merci allez super en plus
évidemment je peux pas esquiver alors je
sais pas si c'est une référence au film
quand il sort de l'eau mais dans le film
il fait juste que sortir de l'eau il
fait pas du jet ski bordel de merde
enfin bon de toute façon ce jeu est
tellement [ __ ] enfin je veux dire qu un
moniteur est attaqué le compteur de 1
minute se déclenche mais contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait penser ça veut pas
dire que tu as une minute pour le sauver
hein c'est plutôt que genre il va perdre
de la vie pendant une minute avant que
sa vie n'atteigne zéro donc ça veut dire
que même si je fonce et que je Tu Jon
direct le temps que je traverse la carte
et ben le moniteur il aura quand même
perdu de la vie et du coup la situation
qui est complètement conne vis-à-vis de
l'histoire c'est que Jason étant
tellement dur à battre était monit
tellement important à
économiser finalement quand c'est un
enfant qui se fait attaquer ben oh mon
dieu j'ai est en train de massacré un
enfant
[Musique]
oui donc ce que je voulais dire c'est
que par rapport du coup finalement le
but étant de tuer Jason il faut perdre
le moins de temps possible à se déplacer
entre les maisons parce que sinon tes
moniteurs perdent de la vie le temps que
tu viennes pour les sauver donc il faut
regrouper tous les moniteurs dans la
même zone pour pouvoir naviguer
facilement de maison en maison et
attirer Jason pour oh va te faire
[Musique]
[ __ ] je vois qu'il y a pas beaucoup
de monde ce
soir mon cher Petitfils ah m'appelez pas
comme ça vous êtes même pas mon
grand-père vous êtes juste un personnage
qu'on a écrit à l'AR rche peut-être ou
peut-être que je suis un extraterrestre
poège la galaxie des Chinois et c'est
quoi cet accent là je suis n à
perpignant
[ __ ] écr vraiment de la
merde il est temps de reprendre le test
mon
Cherier je sais plus où est le salon tu
sais tu es sur un fond vert finalement
tu es là où tu as envie d'être ok donc
du coup ça veut dire qu'on va passer sur
Do Mister HDE sorti en 88 sur NES adapté
d'un vieux roman de 1886 alors même si
vous avez jamais lu le livre ou vu les
films ce qui est très probable vous avez
cela dit au moins une fois forcément vu
une parodie de doct Jacky and mrter Hyde
tout le monde l'a parodié hein les
Simpson Tom et Jerry moi par exemple la
première fois que je l'ai vu parodier
c'était dans le jeu Titi et grominé sur
megga Drive vous avez Titi qui buvait
une potion et qui devenait un gros
monstre et bien docteur Jacky Mr Heide
c'est ça le docteur jacky est une
gentille personne mais avec une double
personnalité il décide de mettre au
point une potion pour essayer de séparer
son côté gentil de son côté méchant mais
finalement ça ne marche pas et ça le
transforme en son côté méchant Mister
Hyde donc dans ce jeu on joue le docteur
jackill qui se promène dans Londres et
au début tout va très bien il fait beau
les gens se promènent les enfants
essayent de t'assassiner les femmes te
tabassent les gens en costard font des
attentats à la bombe les animaux
t'agressent les oiseaux te chitsus bref
une journée complètement normale dans la
vie de héros de jeu vidéo pourri enfin
je veux dire j'aurais pu comprendre ça
si je jouer en Mister he mais je joue en
docteur Jacky je suis censé être un
gentil docteur qui est aimé par les gens
c'est quoi cette ville de merde
bonjour monsieur
jackill bonjour Docteur ah bonjour
Docteur à demain pour mon
[Musique]
rendez-vous je vais déménager en
fait et surtout j'arrive pas à définir
ce qui rend les gens fous en fait de ce
que je comprends et les vrais ennemis
c'est surtout les enfants avec leur
frondes et surtout les mecs en rose là
qui sont les terroristes les plus
classes du monde bonjour JEH belle
journée n'est-ce pas bombe je peux rien
faire pour l'éviter parce que je
rappelle que le bouton B ne sert à rien
tu peux rien taper avec et surtout c'est
débile vu que tous les mecs qui posent
des bombes sont en rose ça va au bout
d'un moment je devrais les voir venir
défends-toi un peu merde oh mais non le
seul monstre que tu peux tuer dans ce
jeu c'est les abeilles et attention pas
les araignées juste les abeilles c'est
une canne à abeilles et les abeilles
aussi d'ailleurs c'est le seul monstre
qui ne t'emmerde pas voilà c'est un jeu
où tu peux juste tuer les trucs plus
inoffensifs que toi alors que je puisse
pas les tuer avant qu'il posent leur
bombes bon ben ça serait pas grave si
l'explosion des bombes n'était pas 100 %
aléatoire mais regarde ça là là je le
prends pas là pourquoi je veux dire des
fois je suis à 2 cm de l'explosion je
prends zéro dégâts des fois je suis à 10
[ __ ] de mètres et je la prends ça
m'enlève toute ma [ __ ] de vie [ __ ]
de [ __ ] de [ __ ] de merde je déteste
l'aléatoire vous savez quoi les gens qui
programment ça on devrait faire un truc
quand vous arrivez à votre bureau le
matin on tire un D et sur un score de 1
à 3 au lieu de vous laisser travailler
on vous [ __ ] merde donc bon quand vous
perdez toute votre barre de santé
mentale vous vous transformez en Mister
RideOn je vais passer sur le fait que ça
n'a aucun sens parce que je rappelle que
dans l'histoire Mister HDE il est censé
se transformer en buvant une potion et
pas en se faisant martyriser comme si
c'était Hulk là et tu arrives en fait
dans la partie la plus intéressante du
jeu enfin intéressant c'est un bien
grand mot la Seconde Guerre mondiale ça
c'est intéressant là c'est plutôt bon la
[Musique]
partie moins quand tu joues avec HDE tu
es transporté dans le même monde en mode
miroir rempli de monstres des cerveaux
avec des pieds des étoiles de mer qui
volent des bouffoud ou SOS fantô et le
but c'est de récupérer ta santé mentale
aussi vite que possible en tuant des
monstres avant d'arriver à l'endroit où
tu es mort avec jkill sinon tu meurs et
c'est le game over définitif alors
encore une fois j'ai pas lu le livre
mais je ne pense pas que dedans il y ait
de mondes post-apocalyptique démoniaque
dans lequel tu tires des boules de feu
et je parle de boules de feu mais ces
boules de feu c'est la tristesse du
désespoir c'était sûrement trop
classique de faire des boules de feu en
ligne droite alors ils se sont sûrement
dit qu'ils allaient faire un [ __ ] de
concours de slalom regardez-moi cette
circonférence regardez-moi cette esquive
parfaite de l'ennemi c'est une œuvre
d'art c'est incroyable alors j'ai deux
armes dans ce niveau les boules de feu
de merde qui toucheent rien et le coup
de point de merde qui touche encore
moins que rien mais qu'en plus tu te
prends toi aussi des dégâts quand tu
l'utilises expliquez-moi pourquoi est-ce
que j'irais utiliser le coup de point
qui fait que quand je l'utilise je me
prends des dégâts moi aussi alors que
j'ai les boules de feu finies enfin bref
donc ces niveaux servent à deux choses
récupérer des pièces pour faire fermer
leur gueule aux chanteuses dans le mode
normal et évidemment comme je disais
récupérer assez de santé mentale pour
revenir jouer dans le mode normal sauf
que je veux pas retourner dans le monde
normal je veux rester là dans l'autre
monde tout le monde veut me tuer et on
me chie dessus et un autre détail dont
j'ai pas parlé
c'est je je vais où là je fais quoi je
veux dire au début du jeu on voit le
docteur jackill qui sort se balader mais
je vais où donnez-moi un but un objectif
je sais pas moi acheter du pain s ve une
princesse dans la rivière n'importe quoi
mais me laissez pas me faire péter la
rondelle gratuitement dans la rue sans
aucune raison bordel parce que bon ça va
au début tu avances bien jeux vidéo fun
lol et cetera mais plus tu réussis à
avancer loin plus le jeu devient
stupidement dur je veux dire regardez ça
j'ai atteint la banlieu j'ai à Ban lieu
c'est pour ça que les gens sont si
vénères arrêtez de courir comme si on
était sur un [ __ ] de stade de
rugby j'arrive pas à avancer j'arrive
pas à passer cette [ __ ] d'araignée ah
non en plus je suis obligé d'attendre
que l'araignée soit bien tout en haut
pour passer sauf que là c'est la guerre
civile c'est complètement la guerre
merde [ __ ] laissez-moi passer
laissez-moi passer cette
[Musique]
araignée c'est incroyable c'est moins
dur dans le monde de l'enfer que dans le
monde réel les Anglais ils sont plus
vénère que les monstres c'est en plus
mon perso il est lent [ __ ] mais marche
plus vite vite et en plus chaque fois
que je me fais toucher je repars en
arrière même quand un truc me fonce dans
le dos je repars en arrière je suis
tellement une [ __ ] de victime et si au
moins je pouvais me défendre mais non si
au moins ma canne pouvait taper des gens
ou les immobiliser je dis pas mais là
j'ai rien je suis à poil quoi de une
arme donnez-moi une arme ou un bouton
pour me protéger au moins enfin même si
j'avais un lancefamme le jeu il serait
dur alors sans rien mais vous êtes
complètement con ma parole c'est quoi
votre prochain jeu là Candy contre le 3è
Reich regardez ça ils ont appelé l'armée
ils ont appelé la [ __ ] d'armée qui me
tire des obus sur la gueule et [ __ ]
mais ça finit jamais je vous jure je
suis un poil de cul vir3 de devenir
complètement cinglé ça fait des heures
que je joue que j'avance que je passe de
village en cimetière de cimetière en
village je suis où là je vais où est-ce
qu'il y a une FA à ce jeu au moins ou
est-ce que c'est une une espèce de monde
pur atoire du jeu vidéo où tu avances
éternellement dans la souffrance pour
laver tes péchés est-ce qu'il y a une FA
ce jeu
[Musique]
alors les scrip te
plît ça fera une bonne vidéo tu trouves
pas les gens vont
adorer où est Karim oh mais il est là
regarde il a déjà mis un pouce vert
un pouce vert contre les Chinois un
pouce vert pour la
justice un pouce
ver pu là en fait ça pourrait revenir
sur nous et on sera en fait en train
d'écrire le
script et puis on regarde la caméra et
les crédit
arriv maintenant
étrange n'est-ce pas peut-être est
prédestiné peut-être est ah merde faut
aussi faire revenir le narrateurtoi
c'est en cours déjà